Thank you.
Y'All have comics there,
so actually don't have to talk,
which would be great.
Um,
you'll have to bear with me.
I still get nervous occasionally and talks,
especially when I'm speaking to,
um,
computery people cause I'm,
I'm not,
I'm not a computer people that are computer person at all.
Um,
which is,
uh,
what makes it strange to be talking on technical subjects at Google a fair few
times.
So,
um,
uh,
this is me normally.
Um,
I'm a animator cartoonists.
Uh,
my day job is a,
is this sort of thing.
Um,
there's will effects,
uh,
which I do do on computers,
but very reluctantly,
um,
I started on iron giant hand drawn on paper,
like medieval peasant.
Um,
nowadays of course,
uh,
we do everything on a,
on these big machines,
um,
which I actually used to resent,
uh,
quite a bit.
Um,
which is strange.
It's strange that I wound up doing this comic about these two crazy kids.
Um,
if you don't know who they are,
you might've kind of briefly pass by them in computers.
When on one,
uh,
Charles Babbage,
Ada Lovelace,
um,
I first met them in 2009 a when a friend of mine,
Sue Sharman,
started Ada Lovelace day,
which you might've heard of,
um,
sort of online festival of women in computing.
And,
uh,
we were in a pub and she said,
said you should,
you're a woman in tech,
uh,
you should do a comic,
like,
uh,
you should do a post for Ada Lovelace day.
Um,
so I said,
I don't even know who ada Lovelace is an I'm also not really in tech.
Um,
so I just quickly Wikipedia at her like anybody would do.
And uh,
um,
it was just such an extraordinary story.
Uh,
and to me struck me as very comic booky.
Um,
so I just sat down in an evening instead of dashed off the following,
a chronic,
which,
um,
this is cleaned up from its initial appearance.
Um,
and this was just a to introduce,
uh,
in laplace and Charles Babbage to people who might not know who they are.
Um,
so,
um,
Lord Byron,
famous poet,
uh,
and that case,
was married to Annabella Milbanke amateur mathematician.
Um,
they split when Aiden was about a year old.
it had never met her father.
He fled the country and a cloud of scandal,
never came back.
Um,
and it,
his mother was very concerned that she would inherit her father's wild blood
when people call this political tendency.
Um,
so,
uh,
it is mothers,
kind of solution to this was to a trainer and mathematics logic and science.
Um,
so she had a very unusual education for girl.
Charles Babbage,
uh,
Lucasian professor of mathematics,
a position held by Newton,
currently held by Stephen Hawkings.
So you can tell he's a pretty clever guy and his own age.
He was extremely famous for,
um,
these mysterious calculating machines that he was burning through government
money.
Uh,
designing.
the most famous is the difference engine,
mostly because the name is really cool.
And it also has a book,
uh,
the difference engine written about what if you had built it.
Um,
they met in 1833,
um,
and um,
in a immediately fell madly in love with this machine.
Um,
the,
uh,
the fragment of the difference engine you can still see in the science museum.
So wonderful objects,
but this big made of brass.
Um,
that's the only part that was ever built of any of these machines.
but the one that she,
when she was really intrigued with was,
um,
the,
uh,
oh,
sorry,
this is a,
this gag,
uh,
this guy I think might have spelled my doom.
Um,
so,
um,
after she met Bev and she immediately asked me for the blueprints for this
device,
she was very,
very keen on machinery.
She'd always been,
um,
kind of a fan of taking apart a little machines and Clark's,
I'm doing factory tours,
that sort of thing.
Um,
so she was very,
very keen on this,
uh,
device.
But,
um,
when she was really into was the analytical engine,
which was Babbage's next piece of vaporware,
uh,
which was,
um,
a,
she liked the difference engine.
So the difference engine was a machine for addition,
uh,
to do,
to print logarithmic tables.
Um,
it was basically a gigantic adder that could print,
um,
uh,
in order to,
to print these books of tables that would be used by actuaries or navigators or
whoever.
Um,
pretty much the same year he meant Ada in the early 1830s.
Babbage came up with an idea for a much more complex machine.
Um,
the analytical engine would be,
um,
would first of all have a memory so it could store the results and that it could
feed the results back into the machine and use them.
Uh,
and the whole thing was programmed with punch cards.
Um,
and a little later in the talk,
I'll show you a kind of how it worked,
um,
in pretty much every possible way except for being made of brass and driven by
steam.
It was a computer.
Um,
Babbage worked on very,
very elaborate designs.
Thousands of pages of notebooks on this machine.
Um,
unfortunately because he had already failed to build us considerably less
complicated machine,
he wasn't able to secure any more funding for his analytical engine.
Um,
but he worked on it for many years.
for Ada,
it was this machine that she was incredible,
very deeply fascinated with.
Um,
she knew Babbage for about a decade before writing this paper that she's okay,
Ms Four.
Um,
and um,
she being a woman,
of course her position had to be,
uh,
kind of on the side looking in.
Um,
but her kind of big chance came.
And,
uh,
42 when,
um,
there was a publication,
uh,
in a French paper from an Italian who had transcribed a speech of Babbage's in
Trenton,
a in Italy.
Um,
this was the only really public presentation Babbage had ever done on the
analytical engine.
He was not secretive about it,
but he wasn't really pushing it that much.
Um,
so ada took this paper and translated it into English because translation was a
acceptable position for a woman in science at that time.
Um,
however,
because she was so,
um,
uh,
into this machine and because she had many ideas of her own,
about it,
she,
um,
again adding footnotes,
uh,
and when the paper came out in 43,
I should say this is from the original comics.
So this is actually the wrong date.
Uh,
in 43,
the paper,
the her on notes were republished and the footnotes for boats three times as
long as the original paper that she was transcribing.
Um,
and in that foot in those footnotes has all sorts of really interesting things.
the first description of a loop,
for example,
um,
some wonderful programs,
I guess you would call them in a way.
Um,
and her thoughts on the engine,
which we'll get into later.
Um,
this is the program renewing numbers.
It's more of what you'd now call a state table.
It's just describing the setup of the machine in each a particular kind of
iteration of what it's doing.
Um,
unfortunately,
of course I love lace,
died a very young 18,
30,
six years old.
Um,
and beverage never did finish any of these machines.
so,
um,
this is me,
you know,
kind of coming to the end of the story and Wikipedia and thinking,
well I can't end the comic like that.
That's,
you know,
weren't right.
You know,
that's a really demanding.
So I added the following panel.
Um,
I,
I think I was vaguely aware of steam punk is a thing.
I didn't read the difference engine,
this famous book where they actually build a machine.
But uh,
I'd heard of it.
So,
uh,
I just added this to be of a nice punch line to the comic.
I think I was thinking of the Avengers
if you see them actually.
Um,
I also added the following,
cause I'm sending you to bear in mind is I do hate computers very much.
So.
Um,
there were two big misconceptions about this panel.
The first misconception is that,
um,
turned up in a all sort of all over the Internet a couple of days after I put up
this little comic strip,
all of which you have seen at this stage.
Um,
it turned up,
I think in wired and a couple of other places saying this person is going to do
a comic about Ada Lovelace and Charles Babbage fighting crime,
um,
which I had no intention of doing.
This was a joke.
Um,
the other misconception is that they're super heroes.
They are not,
they are clearly super villains
because they invented this horrible thing that computer,
um,
you know,
which was the misery of my life,
uh,
pretty much every day.
Um,
so the gag here is eight of course,
was raised to destroy all poetry and um,
Charles Babbage,
famous as he was for inventing these calculating machines was much more famous
at the end of his life for his crusade against street music,
um,
which made him infamous in late Victorian England and find more well done.
I'm very suggestible and I was putting off working on something else.
So,
uh,
I started this comic,
a treaty goggles and it was very,
very,
very informal.
Um,
it was really just a way of blowing off steam at the end of the day and to draw
as well,
because in animation,
of course we don't draw,
we manipulate objects in three d space.
Um,
so I miss drying and I was like,
if I draw a little comic,
uh,
in this comic,
they fight crime,
uh,
they fight crime badly cause otherwise it wouldn't be funny.
Um,
I think the thing that,
uh,
kind of,
eventually through a strange series of events from resulted me and being here,
uh,
is Google books.
And I'm really not just saying this because I originally designed this talk for
Google books
in California.
Um,
Google books was,
is what transformed this from a kind of little squib of a comic into something
that I think was genuinely interesting.
Um,
the comic began,
uh,
when Google books was a very early stages,
um,
and it was dumping the 19th century,
a searchable online in a way that had never happened before.
Um,
and that meant any random clown such as me,
uh,
could just type Babbage Lovelace into these search terms and turn up,
just sheer amounts of stuff.
Um,
this is very typical.
I think the first thing that I was really surprised to find was that beverage
and Lovelace were very,
very famous people in their period Lovelace was a celebrity child.
Um,
and uh,
Babbage was actually a big time celebrity himself as this sort of intellectual
who had invented this amazing thing that nobody could understand.
Um,
so this is from the Deseret news in Utah.
just a piece of anecdotes about them,
which is very commonly the way this shows up.
Um,
I like this one beverage,
the log with medical Frankenstein,
lovely stuff,
shows up considerably less than vantage.
Um,
uh,
yeah.
Um,
they love,
they say he was amused by my saying that babies are not,
Byron should have been her father.
She was apparently a bit of a bore.
That's one of the things that you can get out of people's anecdotes about her is
that she was a bit of a drag talking about mathematics,
uh,
at dinner parties,
which I advise you not to do.
Um,
so you get a ton of stuff on Babbage all the time.
Not so much about Lovelace because she's much more,
um,
uh,
being female.
Of course she's the less public figure,
but,
um,
it was enough to kind of,
start adding these little bits to the blog.
So this is the way that the blog developed.
Um,
this would be the end of the comic.
Here's Ada Lovelace being chased by monkeys is,
uh,
of course you are.
And then,
uh,
then they'd be followed by all these footnotes,
which would be whatever stuff I had found a online,
um,
just sort of browsing around,
training methods of Oregon grinders,
monkeys,
the Bridgewater treatise,
which was this
bring the baby trout.
So,
um,
through that
kind of combination of improvising online and reading,
uh,
I guess eye witness accounts of them in the period I was constructing these
characters,
and they're very consciously comic book characters.
They're not intended as a kind of reproduction of them as historical people,
but they're there,
I guess a riff for an improvisation on them.
Um,
love Olsen,
he was Babbage.
Um,
damage is always very easy to draw it because he wrote it tons of stuff
actually,
even though,
weirdly the only thing he didn't write about was the analytical engine.
He wrote about taxation and he wrote about copyright and he wrote this massive
autobiography that's super entertaining.
Very,
very funny.
Janie guy.
Um,
so his personality,
super clear.
I was really pleased to find this in punch a,
so this is him in 1852 he's really angry that his,
um,
they didn't put it as a,
the engine,
the difference engine bid and the grid exhibition.
Uh,
so he's,
uh,
he was only honorably mentioned,
so he's pretty mad how,
but I think,
you know,
he comes out,
this is a,
so,
um,
just to kind of,
I said I talk about my process of creative transformation,
so I guess that's what I'll do.
So this is,
um,
the,
uh,
New York near 1833 this is the same year she might Babbage.
Um,
I don't,
if you can't read it,
it says,
oh fine.
And a said that eight of Byron sole daughter of the noble borrowed is the most
course and vulgar woman in England.
Um,
which is one of those things that,
you know,
it's very intriguing and it's true in her letter,
she does swear,
which is very unusual.
The terrain women.
Um,
this is something else I found.
This is from,
uh,
this is actually from beverages pamphlet on the great exhibition,
which is mostly about why isn't my engine integrative submission and where he's
describing what it can do.
And one of the things that he describes is the world's first error pop up.
Um,
if you put the wrong logarithm in it,
we'll put a plate that would snap up and say wrong.
Um,
and is that a bag of enc continually ringing loud?
Bell
should be fantastic.
I'm sure if you were the guy in charge of the machine.
Um,
so with this,
I came up with the eight.
All of this is debugging a whenever programs here in the engine
Babbage's showing the engine to Queen Victoria of course.
Um,
so the comic,
I,
you know,
generally speaking,
if you read the book,
it's,
it's mostly me making fun of computers and you just using these hapless people
as my,
uh,
tools for this.
Um,
but I was able to find as well,
um,
some really magical stuff in Google books and I guess,
you know,
important unimportant but,
but
really important stuff as well.
Um,
this is a letter that
certainly had been lost,
um,
to scholarships if it hadn't been for do little books because it's only appears
as far as I know,
in a very obscure,
a journal called the southern review,
um,
Maryland 18
before,
um,
and they're just printing letters
home from people and just random stuff and there's yeah,
die who met damage in there.
Um,
and we have here
show spoke highly of a mathematical powers under peculiar capability,
higher see,
said the net of anyone he knew to prepare,
I believe it was the descriptions connected with is calculating machine.
Um,
he says,
I fear not expressing myself rightly here.
So the precise nature of the subject,
I think he's the descriptions is the state tables,
the programs,
um,
which is like,
you know,
it's pretty magical to find something like that.
Um,
there's a,
it's quite long.
He goes,
he really goes into,
um,
kind of the relationship.
It's a couple of years after Ada had died.
Um,
so that kind of,
uh,
thing,
you know,
this.
So I guess the intersection between scholarship and primary sources and then
just improvisation and imagination that that's what the comic was basically
about.
Um,
so,
um,
these two characters,
I think,
uh,
you know,
became pretty clear to me.
Um,
when I had to sit down to write a book,
I didn't have to sit down to write a book that they told me to write a book.
So I wrote a book.
There was a third character that a I had to come to grips with and that was the
analytical engine.
Um,
the analytical engine in the comic appears like this.
this is George Eliot,
uh,
getting her novels spellchecked uh,
in machine,
she gets lost in almost eaten.
But,
uh,
um,
in the comic,
the machine,
like the way it's,
I actually described by contemporary people and even by Babbage and even by
Lovelace,
you just get this impression of this enormous bunch of cogs doing something.
Um,
and it's very complicated and you can't understand it.
but,
um,
uh,
because I had so much primary stuff about a beverage and Lovelace,
I felt I had to have,
now here's the real analytical engine.
Um,
so I sat down to do a visualization,
um,
and I was very upset to find that no one had done one that I could rip off.
Um,
I had was the Babbage plans.
So this is,
um,
plan 25 and this is a pretty famous image.
You might've seen it in computer street books.
Um,
but,
um,
actually it's a lot more ambiguous than it might seem.
Um,
you know,
these are the cards,
the famous punch cards,
but how are they attached and where do they go?
Are they up?
Are they down?
Are they to scale?
Um,
uh,
Babish left,
not a lot of elevations,
which makes it hard to kind of understand the machine.
Um,
so I had to sit down with these plans and I have to say also used,
um,
the scholarly work of Alan Bromley,
the late Allen Brownlee who really went through and explained the mathematics of
the machine,
um,
with extreme detail.
So between the Bromley papers and the diagrams,
I was able to do some elevations.
Come on.
There we go.
MMM.
That's the scale.
It's a really big machine.
Um,
to get a sense of kind of the reality of this thing.
and using that I was able to produce this,
which was the first,
um,
visualization to my knowledge of the machine.
Um,
it should be fairly accurate ish.
I,
I have a feeling it couldn't have been free standing like this,
um,
just because of the sheer weight of the thing I have.
I think it would have probably have to be in with those warehouse buildings
basically embedded into the structure.
Uh,
uh,
pretty heavy FTE building.
Um,
but um,
oh,
go over how this machine works.
Uh,
cause that's kind of my purpose for being here I suppose.
Um,
so this is the a store,
um,
which is the memory basically.
Um,
it's a lot easier to describe this machine,
um,
in,
uh,
Maya actually,
so I'm going to switch over.
Um,
Babbage himself said that one of the reasons he didn't describe his machine very
much was because it's difficult to explain,
um,
how it works without being able to show it.
And boy,
is he ever right because,
um,
I find it impossible to explain without,
uh,
without,
and I found it actually impossible to understand,
uh,
without basically building it and animating it.
Um,
but that wound up being a really,
really good tool.
Um,
so this is just a slice of it,
uh,
to see how the whole thing looks.
Turn on who,
here's my name and convention whole thing.
Okay.
There we go.
So
I'm on
as you can,
you can see why I'm only using a slice.
It's,
it's,
my laptop is pretty strong,
but it's really struggling with the,
um,
there we go.
There we go.
Okay.
So,
um,
when you're looking at here is a machine for manipulating very large numbers and
that's what Babbage,
uh,
designed it for.
And every single piece of the machine is to add,
subtract,
multiply,
divide large numbers as quickly as possible.
Um,
the machine was not designed to produce a single result.
It was designed to run through iterations of a formula to print out into books.
Um,
so basically what you would have is,
you know,
we need x formula for life insurance.
You know,
what are the premiums if you're such and such an age and it would just run down
and print for each success of age,
uh,
what the statistics are.
Um,
that's the sort of thing this machine was for.
MMM.
Each of these columns is a number,
um,
Babbage specified 50 digits for his ideal machine.
So these are 50 gears and the way you store a number is you just turn each gear.
So if you want to put 351,
you go three,
five,
one places on each gear and you just go down.
Um,
even I can understand that part.
So I'd say it's pretty straight forward,
um,
as to how much storage he had.
Everyone wants more memory.
I think Babbage said,
you know,
ideally a thousand places.
Now you can see if I pop back to the design,
he puts the memories sort of running off the page.
So I'm sure he would have ideally added more and more memory to that,
um,
and the memory and just goes off
into the distance.
So I turn that off.
So each layer,
all of that height is only because it's such big numbers that it's for.
Um,
so the mass of the machinery is,
is just replicating up the decimal places.
Um,
so I'm just a,
this is just a very super,
super,
super simplified demo with one,
which is quality here,
um,
with one decimal place just to kind of go through,
this amazing machine,
uh,
because it's,
it's an absolute thing of beauty.
And when you consider this was designed in 1830s and forties by a guy with,
you know,
literally a feather and some and candles.
Um,
it's pretty amazing because this was all held in his head.
it took three types of card to run the machine,
a number card,
variable card.
This is the addressing system basically.
Uh,
and the operations card,
which has the program itself.
Um,
fortunately,
very recently,
um,
I had some lovely pictures sent to me by Bruce Sterling actually.
Um,
uh,
who's into Rin and found,
um,
some of the stuff that Babbage left when he gave his
talk there.
Um,
this is the number of cards sample that he left.
So this is pine written on the number of card and you can see the way the card
is written.
Is that the important places?
So three has three and punched holes.
Okay.
Um,
was an operations card come back to that in a sec.
But if you look at the,
let's go,
if we go back to the number of card,
the whole machine was built off of the principle of the jacquard loom.
Um,
if you ever see one of those,
all that that happens with the moon is that you have go to the,
a number of cards over here.
So you'd have an array and you know,
and a number card,
you'd have like 10,
10 little leavers for 50 decimal places.
It's like 500 little leavers.
This is actually not,
um,
a 500.
I didn't go that crazy with it,
but um,
it would have been an extremely complicated machine.
Um,
and the way it works is the um,
the card,
the spindle pushes the card forward.
If there's a hole,
it just goes through the lever and nothing happens.
If there's not a whole,
then the leaver pushes forward and basically engages some part of the machine to
the power underneath the machine or cams continually turning.
I'm driven presumably by the steam engine that's puffing away and corner.
Um,
and the lever,
we'll just hook up something to the cam and it will go either up and down and
round and round.
That's basically the two things that cam can do,
but if you put them together in clever ways,
you can do some pretty good stuff.
Um,
so that's how the cards work.
The way the machine works is,
first thing that happens is the variable card,
which I always called them address cards just because it's a lot clearer to me
to think of this as the addressing system.
And this would have a whole,
I presume for each position in the memory.
So you would eventually a ginormous card unless you came up with some more
clever system.
Um,
and that just depresses the lever,
which hooks up its corresponding section in the memory to a little opinion.
Then the number card
sort of red means it's driving green means it's bringing driven,
um,
it's just a bit clearer to understand,
uh,
that way.
So,
um,
then the number card we'll read
just by turning,
all it does is just say turn three places to however many places there are no
holes in this section.
So,
um,
that turns three places.
So three,
the Rocco,
three places,
pinion goes three places,
gear goes through places,
it's not reading.
Three,
um,
disengage.
So then it reads in another number.
Variable cards selects the address,
number card reads out a number into it.
Um,
these cards are runs completely separately.
So when you're setting up the program,
you're wrangling three completely separate cars and you're really better hope
that you've got them in the right order.
And then it was,
you've got those popups.
So,
um,
right now the operations card
is to me where the real beauty of the machine is
going to pop over to the operations card here.
Oh,
there we go.
Um,
you can see here,
this is Babbage's on handwriting.
Um,
he has all the functions add,
subtract,
multiply,
divide,
systemic straighting a division.
Um,
it's also about these two holes.
Ad Rotation,
subtract rotation.
That means the machine could instruct itself to go back or forward depending on
the state of the machine.
Um,
and I'll kind of explain how that works.
So in a second.
Yeah.
Um,
so how could you go through such a complex procedure with a single hole?
because addition alone took several dozen steps of many,
many different bits of machinery.
The way he did that is with the barrels.
Uh,
which is funny because he actually took these from the barrel organs.
I bet he hated so much.
Um,
but he must have loved that mechanism cause he,
he stuck these barrels all over the place.
Uh,
and the way that he uses them is that the operations card will say,
you know,
add,
let's say push forward and then the barrels will rotate to a wedge of
instructions.
So all that,
uh,
the add a position,
does it say,
go to the ad,
a set of instructions.
Um,
and what does that set up?
The numbers that an ordered from the variable card.
Okay.
Uh,
variable hooks up.
It's got
its own barrel.
Any,
any of the cards are using barrels because they need to run through a bunch of
stuff.
Sorry.
Um,
and that reads off their designated address into the ingress access,
uh,
which then reads it off into these wonderful wheels.
I love these things.
Uh,
he got rid of these in the later,
um,
designs for the machine,
which is sad cause I,
I love the clarity of this sort of giant data transfer thing in the middle.
Um,
so this will send,
uh,
the number two,
this section,
each of these sections in the mill,
um,
back to look at the,
uh,
so each of these sections is specialized earring.
Um,
and it's,
it's largely adding,
um,
stuff but just special types of addition.
And it just says,
okay,
go to the adding section.
Yeah.
So it feeds the one number in,
picks up another number is that one in a,
and then the barrels just go through their little routine.
Um,
this obviously is a cartoon there.
There is,
these are really,
really complicated bits of the bits of gear.
Um,
but I just put this together for my own kind of in this nation.
so they run through their instruction set.
There's the result,
the variable cards select the address that they want the result to read out to.
That's fed into the egress access.
Sir,
I'll put,
I guess we'd call it now,
fair.
Bocard's pickup.
Uh,
you know,
give the a where they want that to me too.
And that reads off and done.
Um,
it had a very,
uh,
although she's known kind of generally as the first programmer.
That's not actually first of all true or second of all that critical.
Obviously Babbage wrote programs for the machine when he was designing it.
They're much simpler than that Bernoulli one,
uh,
which he and Ada collaborated on,
which is in the paper.
Um,
but,
uh,
Babbage also had assistance that might have written some simple programs for it.
Um,
so she wasn't the first and she wasn't kind of there at his elbow writing
programs for him.
Um,
in any case,
she herself complained a lot about their state tables.
When she wrote the papers.
She was like,
this is a huge pain and it's really annoying and fiddly and,
uh,
you know,
this is a McCount is stamina.
Um,
what,
uh,
it is the actual main interest in the machine was in connecting it with the
ideas of this guy,
uh,
who was her mathematics tutor who's Augustus to Morgan.
Um,
if you've heard of do Morgan's laws,
this is that to Morgan.
Um,
Demorian basically took,
uh,
you know,
through his university college London course,
um,
which she had just started obviously as a woman she go,
but he took her through it by correspondence.
Um,
he was a family friend.
I'm not something they paid or anything like that.
They hung out,
I guess you could say.
Um,
and at the same time that love that was hanging out with Babbage.
She was also hanging out with Morgan at the time that the Morgan was developing
a mathematical system of logic.
This is 10 years before boule.
Um,
you can see what Dee Dee Morgan's logic looks like here.
He's trying to find a way to turn it into mathematical formulas.
Um,
and for Lovelace,
she looked at this one
click.
Uh,
I think for lovelies being kind of in proximity with these two ideas in ferment
of Babbage's machine for manipulating numbers and to Morgan's concept of logic
as mathematics,
which was very,
very,
very new.
I mean,
Morgan was really pretty much one of the first people who was doing this sort of
thing.
Um,
this kind of led her pop up past that.
Uh,
this is a two,
they're probably her most famous passage in the paper,
which is to link the two together and say this is not necessarily a arithmetic
machine.
This can be
logic machine.
Um,
she says,
uh,
the position holding its own,
um,
in enabling mechanism to combine together general symbols.
She's Victorian.
So it takes a long time to get through a sentence.
Um,
in six sessions,
I haven't limited variety and extent are uniting.
Link is established between the operations of matter and the abstract mental
processes at the most abstract branch of math,
medical science and you vast and powerful language is developed for the future
use of analysis.
Um,
she comes back to this idea again and again in the paper that,
um,
uh,
for example,
she says if you took a musical composition and could find a way to develop it as
a series of instructions,
the machine could be taught to compose music,
scientific music.
She says it can be taught to compose scientific music of unlimited variety and
extent.
Um,
so for me,
looking at this,
sorry,
this is a,
my a eight 11 is programming,
uh,
engine.
I,
I'm always struck by how hard it must've been to keep the cars together.
So designed for her a,
a kind of machine to do that.
Um,
for me too,
it was only when I built this thing,
um,
that I understood what a spectacular leap this was.
Um,
there's nothing in this machine,
uh,
that would even suggest such a thing.
Uh,
to me,
to me the,
and certainly to Babbage,
this is a machine for arithmetic,
fast arithmetic in very large numbers in Babbage's obsession with speed is I
guess a classic hardware guy from what I understand it in that [inaudible] most
of the work that he put into it with to make it faster.
Um,
but lovely Saudi connection with logic with this little bit here and that's the
ad rotation,
subtract rotation instruction on those cards.
Um,
Babish developed for that,
this little thing called the conditional arm.
And that would drop down if when the machine hit say a certain result or certain
level of results that it would then instruct the machine to stop,
for example,
or branch to go a different,
uh,
to go to a different set of instructions.
S let me see animation of that.
There we go.
So while the barrels are going away,
you can see if there's a peg
and the arms in place.
Um,
then it instructs the machine to do something different.
and this is a logic.
This is an if and logic system.
Um,
and it's this tiny piece here.
I think that [inaudible] saw the possibilities of,
um,
if you stripped away all the gears,
which,
you know,
90% of the machine is just numbers.
If you take that all away and you just look at this and you start thinking of
what you can do with that,
um,
it's a pretty beautiful,
even to me,
uh,
who hates computers,
just to remind you.
Um,
so,
um,
that's the barrels and the engine and it'll only central's damage and logic and
everything.
So I think that's my talk.
Thank you.